hey guys my name is Jess this is Dan and
uh we've decided to shoot in a brand new
era in the office today why is that Dan
we got bored of the old place and
decided to move about ten minutes ago
yes that's true and is that kind of
forward-thinking that makes us one of
the premier daily gave me a new shows on
games book I think we're the only daily
gaming news show against Bart that's
also true anyway here's the top stories
of the week so after a whole bunch of
rumors and teasing we finally got
treated to nazi zombies Call of Duty
World War two zombies mode we did
Activision released released a trailer
for on a comic-con and their panel and
it looks like a real departure from this
silliness lost from these entries
terrified it does it looks legitimately
looks scary which is something you'd
expect from sledgehammer games which was
founded by two of the guys who came up
with dead space so it's the same as the
usual zombies it's for zombie hunters
surviving hordes of zombies in no doubt
intricate maps that just to get more and
more secrets as it goes on which is
something that I think a lot of people
don't know about zombies it really has
progressed from a simple horde base
defense mode to this insane almost brave
life game and I find it really
interesting and I'm really excited about
this what do you think yeah I mean
hopefully they're continuing to innovate
with it and we do see something
progressively more interesting in a
gameplay and story sense nazi zombies
coming out with Call of Duty World War 2
on November 3rd for PC ps4 and Xbox one
and you can sign up for the beta by
pre-ordering and if you do that you can
get into the beta which is on August
25th so yeah go do it or not do whatever
you want don't you dad
speaking of betas we've been playing a
bunch of the Destiny to beta this week
and with yes we have it's a pretty small
beta than I think people might expect
but it's open right now for everybody on
ps4 and Xbox one so go see for yourself
not to worry if you are on PC you will
be getting it sometime in August so
you'll just have to hang on there but
for those of you who can get into it now
you'll be treated to a beginning mission
and then there's a strike and two pvp
engagements and you can also play
through it all as the three classes
warlock hunter and tighten each of which
have two subclasses for you to mess
around with and there's been some
changes that will be immediately
apparent to returning players so stuff
like the hunter can now dodge the titan
can put up a shield barrier thing that
you can duck behind and the Warlock has
a a pillar of light that can heal
comrades or buff their weapons which is
pretty cool the new
social space the farm is going to be
open for one hour on July 23rd from
10:00 a.m. PC so jump in there and you
can kick around a soccer ball befriended
chickens would you what is that in
Australia then that's 3 a.m. 3 a.m. so I
don't think we'll be playing yeah but
you guys enjoy it for us so when use
it's pretty interesting especially if
you're a big bio whiff and Casey Hudson
here is known for being the director of
the original Mass Effect trilogy left
Bioware in 2014 he's now come back to
replace a GM erin-flynn which is gonna
be really interesting obviously bio is
in a pretty interesting place right now
it sounds like some Dragon Age things
might be happening Andromeda was you
know hit or miss depending on your
opinion there's a small team still
working on Andromeda but a lot of people
have moved over to other projects
including anthem which is by where
Edmonton's current massive project and
that's where Casey's gonna be moving to
he sounds really enthusiastic about it
he said by whoever feels like home so
it's a nice for him to be moving back I
mean personally I've only seen through
things come out of his involvement he
was also involved in games like never
win tonight and that's the Old Republic
which in my opinion are two of the
greatest RPGs of all time so I can't
wait to see him return to by or with one
of the first things I think of when I
hear Red Dead Redemption
who is Ubisoft yeah there was a funny
story this week which is actually one of
the top stories of the week
would you believe Ubisoft have weighed
in on Red Dead Redemption to being too
late
so it's merged out of this year's
release period and they are
understandably their CFO has weighed in
saying that's probably a good thing for
them fiscally I don't think anybody
really wants to compete with the release
of Red Dead Redemption - and it's a it's
a good thing for their q2 games they've
got a huge expansion Hong Kong expansion
for Rainbow six siege coming out in
future they've also got the third season
for honour on the way and of course
Mario Plus Rabbids which is gonna be a
really interesting one they've also got
a fully stacked end of the year with
Assassin's Creed origins and southpaw
coming out in October yeah so the CFR
hasn't gone as far as to say that Red
Dead Redemption 2 being delayed will
mean they're like fiscally gonna be like
way better off but I think they're
cautiously optimistic at the moment that
it might have a good impact for them
so obviously NES classics are going nuts
on E
everybody who didn't quite pick them up
but there's also NES classic games that
have been going for a small fortune
including this particular one which went
from 40 grand
it did Stadium events a sealed copy of
same event went for forty four thousand
nine hundred and seventy seven dollars
and that is just a that's a staggering
amount of money I could buy a Tesla
Model 3 for that stadium events for
anyone who doesn't know was released in
1987 and it was very very limited
release and it came with something
called the family fun pad which was like
a kind of like a dance pad that came out
for ps2 Dance Dance Revolution and stuff
like that it was like a one of the first
exercise games that ever came consoles
the game was originally put up on eBay
for option and then as what usually
happens with eBay the dude who won
didn't peg disappeared so the seller
decided to contact someone who was
serious about it and they paid the money
for a factory sealed copy of that game
and that must have just been sitting in
your garage for years somewhere I mean
making that finding a small fortune in
your desk drawer that's that's my dream
that's why I keep supporting every day
dream yeah well that's GameSpot news for
this week do enjoy your weekend and
enjoy the Destiny to beta if you are
worrying mhm I hope you've enjoyed
today's stories do share your thoughts
on them down in that comment section way
we can check them out I hope you've
enjoyed my attempt to stop saying yeah
so much in a death stories and we will
see you again on Monday hey did you know
that did you know that three models in
fire Tesla's were supposed to spell out
sex but then they didn't want to call
the model a because that was trademarked
by Ford
so Elon Musk went with three so just
that's a little fun tidbit for you